here's the setup for the question it's
got some phrasing in it to be weird some
of you will see it like straight away
but if you like me you kind of scratch
your head over a little bit
they say here are two lines that's the
easy part
okay and they're actual lines so we
could draw these and we will in a second
okay then they say there's some point
they don't tell you where it is it's
just somewhere and it's the same
distance from each of these lines okay
now these lines you can see because the
coefficients of your x and y's don't
match they're not parallel and in fact
they tell you they intersect at a and
they don't tell you where a is but they
say it's some point so being that this
point is the same distance from these
two they say here's your first part
prove this and I don't know about you
but I look at this as my brain kind of
weirds out a little bit because what you
know about absolute value it's like what
but but these two are equal right like
there's no combination of pluses plus
minus this and plus minus that that
makes these two equal to each other and
the answer is they're not equal to each
other like just as a as a statement
about X's and Y's they're equal to each
other for this X and this one okay so
the point P is somewhere it's not just
anywhere random actually it follows some
very obvious geometric rules as you'll
see when we draw it in a second and so
for these X's and Y's these pairs of
coordinates right this statement is true
okay so the algebra is not that hard
it's actually pretty obvious let's see
if I've got the distance from here to
here and then this is from here to here
and they're the same well let's do this
two distances from P so y1 by the way I
call it y1 just so that I could
distinguish between these two okay I've
got the absolute value all
now yeah now my talk I usually have a x1
plus B YY plus C right but it just so
happens just to confuse you a little bit
then your x1 y1
I just X&Y okay so this is my l1 that
I'm comparing I'm just gonna get 2 X 3
that's it that's my ax 1 plus B Y 1 plus
C ok what's on there it's really the
square root of this squared plus this
squared 2 squared plus 1 squared will be
the square root of 5 you agree with that
okay so there's the distance as far as
you can go is nothing else to simplify
that now when you do to line to distance
from point 2 line 2
okay up on the top you get the same
thing happening right you've got
absolute value X minus 2 y plus 1 and
then on the denominator your and B are
different but they're not that different
right you've got one squid and you've
got negative 2 squared and when you
square a man you Adam you still get but
but we've been told we've been told that
P is equidistant from these two in other
words these two are the same so I would
say but but these two distances are
equal right this is given to us in the
question so therefore these two are
equal and they're just fractions over
root 5 so therefore one is equal to the
other right noticing that what are x and
y in this case okay
x and y are the coordinates of this
special point which is equidistant from
these two lines
obviously not all points are equidistant
from these two lines so only some of
them are ok now to make any further
progress
first we'll read the question but then
we're gonna need a picture read the
question with me it says hence find
equations of the lines plural that
bisect the angles at a
hey there's way too much visual language
here for us to move any further without
a picture okay so let's just quickly
take these two lines again let's just
put them in point greater form so we get
a picture of what they're doing what's
this first one I said why this is easy
right I just have two those guys over
okay in this case it's gonna be 1/2 X
plus 1/2 right is that okay
I know you could write excellent too but
I'm just trying to put that gradient
rata the Front's of super obvious okay
so just by coincidence these are
perpendicular they don't need to be okay
but I know what these two look like
let's just quickly and it will help you
this time
even though usually I'm like dad just
put put lines here there wherever okay
let's try to make these actually
reasonably accurate so that we could use
our diagram and make some arguments off
it okay so let's draw each of these
we're going to lie to you by the way
just for the sake of illustration which
one's L wonder which one's L 2 L ones
this good decreasing 1 right L was the
first one I know this is the second one
obviously okay now um where could this
point here which is equidistant from red
lines when it could pave B now you got a
notice straight he is is a variable it
can be in a whole bunch of places okay
but just for the sake of our diagram we
should probably put it in one okay so do
we give me a suggestion that look about
equidistant if I put P there like you
look at that you like there and there
that's about right isn't it okay now I
couldn't I don't have to put me there I
could put it I could put it down feel
right that would work in fact there's a
whole line of points that could satisfy
peas but watch out this is not the only
line that can do it right have a look
I can go yeah I can go this way I could
maybe like every yeah you are here or
here or here or here or here the
question gives you this enormous clue
they says give me the lines the
equations of our lines
plural that bisect this angle here right
so if you've got an angle this is the
end
a right that's one of the acres of a to
slice it in half I can slice it that way
or I could just as easily slice it that
way so I'm gonna get two lines so far so
good okay now how close pay too much
attention to the question again it's one
of those very awkward unfortunate
questions as it says hints hints so we
have to use this result
somehow I'll just put it to you like for
your spare brain cycles right if you
didn't use this if you didn't go through
all this effort if you just got these
lines and I said okay you've got an
angle here and against my sector and
you've got another angle and it also
gets bisected how would you go about
finding those equations hmm okay well we
can find where a is that's that's good
enough okay we can do that but then
after you find a like okay if you've got
a point I assume you do something like
this
right so you can take the corner today
and put that into there okay but then
what's this going to be how would you go
about finding that like I don't want
okay so so you might think about how to
use ten it's a big gross isn't it right
now you can't do it you can't do it but
let's see how we can take advantage of
this